[Music]
you are about to embark on a virtual
journey to one of the most sacred places
on earth nestled in the heart of
Jerusalem's Old City the Church of the
Holy Sepulcher for the faithful it is a
place of pilgrimage and worship for
other visitors it provides a remarkable
look-back at human history and for
scientists and scholars it offers an
opportunity to explore some of the most
enduring questions of the past transcend
history with us and an immersive 3d
experience unlike anything you've
encountered before step into one of the
most holy sites in Christianity
[Music]
and team up with conservation experts as
they raced the clock to restore the tomb
of Christ preserving this revered place
for future generations
[Music]
here at the intersection of history
technology
science
and faith
travel with National Geographic into the
field as we unearth answers to age-old
questions
and uncovered some unexpected surprises
[Music]
we invite you to join us on this
remarkable journey tomb of Christ
the Church of the Holy Sepulchre
experience
[Music]
[Music]